[Música]
Bienvenidos a la crónica de medio
ambiente hoy hablaremos de iniciativas
que le ayudan al planeta y comenzamos en
Europa por primera vez en el viejo
continente se reconoció que un
ecosistema tiene derechos el senado
español aprobó una ley que le da
personalidad jurídica al mar menor Algo
similar buscan en Países Bajos con el
mar del Norte y en Francia con el río
loira desde Madrid nuestra corresponsal
Marina Colorado nos amplía el mar menor
en murcia al sureste del país que es la
mayor Laguna salada del continente
europeo ya es un sujeto de derecho y no
un simple objeto lo novedoso de esta
decisión histórica para España y para
Europa es que se logró gracias a una
iniciativa popular que en dos años
consiguió casi 640.000 firmas para su
tramitación en el parlamento Qué
significa Este cambio Pues que ahora
cualquier persona a título individual
puede denunciar ante un tribunal los
daños que sufre el mar menor y exigir su
para los impulsores de esta iniciativa
El derecho ambiental ha fracasado ya que
a pesar de que este ecosistema cuenta
con otras leyes nacionales e
internacionales a su favor no se ha
salvado del deterioro décadas de
excesivos vertidos de fertilizantes de
plantaciones agrícolas en la región
resultaron en varios episodios de falta
de oxígeno de sus aguas o anoxia que en
tres años han acabado con la vida de
decenas de toneladas de peces la
esperanza ahora es que no sea demasiado
tarde para frenar o revertir el daño
causado que ninguna ley puede ya
subsanar
y mientras en España intentan proteger
en México La Apuesta es por revivir un
producto natural en la Península de
Yucatán históricamente ha habido
henequén que es una fibra tan fuerte y
tan maleable que puede reemplazar al
plástico incluso fue considerado el oro
verde en el siglo 19 y principios del 20
por eso ahora intentan posicionar el
henequén en el mundo con lo que esperan
un nuevo despertar económico Katia
Espinosa nos cuenta
Roberto Balam es uno de los agricultores
que ha decidido comenzar a cosechar el
henequén un producto natural que sirve
de alternativa al plástico para fabricar
cuerdas sogas sacos e hilos aprovecha el
auge Mundial de la demanda de productos
amigables para ayudar con el
resurgimiento de lo que los mayas
llamaban el oro verde
el debacle del LG fue cuando se
iniciaron las bolsas de plástico las
botellas y otras cosas los la soga de
los barcos ya no se utilizaba esos kills
utilizaban otro otra materia que ahí
vino la caída del henequén
cayó como ustedes no se imaginan durante
años el henequén fue considerado el
motor económico de la región de Yucatán
en pro de volver a aquellos tiempos
científicos mexicanos producen súper
plantas de mejor calidad en laboratorios
para repoblar el estado con Esta técnica
el tiempo de cosecha y producción se
reduce a la mitad
el neneken tradicional tarda siete años
en madurar y que pueda ser explotado
industrialmente nuestros henequéns
tardan tres años y medio
con el proyecto de recuperación de estas
plantas también se rescatarán las
desfibradoras de henequén que aún se
mantienen en pie
esta hacienda Fue una típica Hacienda
negra en el sentido de que fue fundada y
vivió y murió en pleno auge de la
prosperidad creada por el congreso
mundial de esta fibra esa fue una de las
1.400 haciendas que se quiere se
situaron en la región
noroestes para la explotación de esta
fibra
con la Ciencia se ha logrado producir
700.000 superplantas entregadas a
alrededor de 100 productores la
intención es reactivar más de 15.000
hectáreas de henequén en 39 municipios
de la zona para que haya un nuevo
despertar económico en la comunidad maya
y de este resurgimiento económico
pasamos al regreso de un felino extinto
en India este país trasladó desde la
sabanas africanas a los primeros ocho
guepardos desde la extinción de la
especie en 1952 en aquel el país
asiático el gobierno y algunos expertos
celebran la medida pero otros consideran
que fue apresurada y que El mamífero no
tiene el hábitat suficiente
el primer viaje intercontinental para un
grupo de guepardos estas cinco hembras y
tres Machos viajaron más de 8.000
kilómetros de Disneylandia en África
hasta India un trayecto de dos días en
helicóptero y avión la especie se
extinguió en India hace 70 años
kuno mezcla al Park
cuando los guepardos corran en el parque
nacional kuno el ecosistema de
pastizales se restaurará y la
biodiversidad aumentará aún más
el ecoturismo también aumentará aquí
aparecerán nuevas posibilidades de
desarrollo
el gobierno ha sido el promotor del
proyecto guepardo que comenzó en 2009 y
que solo en septiembre pasado vio su
logro inicial con la llegada de Los
felinos los primeros de 40
todo el plan cuesta más de 11 millones
de dólares algunos expertos celebran la
decisión diciendo que es un deber moral
recuperar la especie otros lo tildan
como un proyecto vanidoso el guepardo
áfricano es distinto del asiático que
ahora solo se encuentra en Irán en
peligro crítico de extinción además
tuvieron que reubicar a quienes vivían
cerca del Parque cuno y pusieron nuevas
especies para mantener la dieta de los
guepardos
definitivamente tomaron decisiones
apresuradas ya tenemos los animales sin
hacer el trabajo poco glamoroso pero
minucioso y muy esencial de preparar los
hábitats asegurándose de que haya
suficiente área y que tenga suficiente
calidad con bastante presas suficiente
conectividad los animales necesitan un
hogar con suerte Los guepardos se
establecerán y comenzarán a reproducirse
cuando comiencen a reproducirse
necesitarán más espacio y es que los
guepardos necesitan 10 veces más espacio
que los tigres y hasta 40 veces más que
un león
y después de ver estas iniciativas Nos
despedimos vea más en 24.com
[Música]